what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
okay so we are back with infinity war it
only took us three years three years to
finish this so in three more years will
do part three that no we're not we're
not gonna we're gonna finish it all this
week so here is the overall gist of
what's going on really the first video
and I'll actually go back and rename it
the first video is really more of like
an aftermath to Infinity Gauntlet than
anything else what they do bear in mind
is that ever since like 1968 nothing in
Marvel's really existed in real time I
mean there are a couple things here and
there like like the reference things
that exist in real time that would kind
of give us a starting point but by and
large Marvel doesn't reference like
actual dates when it came to the
infinity war story it's really part of a
trilogy and we'll figure out why here in
a second but it's part of a trilogy it's
Infinity Gauntlet infinity war and then
infinity crusade Infinity Gauntlet of
course as most everybody knows Stannis
gets the Infinity Gauntlet all
pandemonium ensues so on and so forth
and things progress exactly as you would
expect they would when Thanos gets
absolute power absolute control over the
universe infinity war happens
immediately after like less than a day
after Infinity Gauntlet starts maybe
maybe a little bit longer but it's
almost right off the bat and so on the
first video what we basically ran over
was it as part of this aftermath there
was basically the trial of Adam warlock
then Infinity Gauntlet ended with Adam
warlock taking the Infinity Gauntlet
and then basically fixing everything
that Thanos had screwed up but
immediately after that happened he was
taken to the dimension of manifestations
which we'll talk about here in a minute
he's taken to this other dimension and
he's basically put on trial by the
Living Tribunal at the request of all
the cosmic entities and because the
Living Tribunal exists to make sure
there's no cosmic imbalance we're just
to say that there's no two versions of
the same cosmic entity more or less
because Thanos sought to replace
eternity the Living Tribunal did not
intervene during Infinity Gauntlet but
because of the fact that Adam warlock
seeks to rule alongside eternity that
creates an imbalance and so ultimately
the Living Tribunal said nope there can
only be one representation of the
universe that's eternity Adam warlock
had not be an equal to it either has to
be above it or below it and so because
of that what ended up happening is
eternity z' response was well then just
disband the the Infinity Gauntlet make
it so no one can use it and that's what
a living tribunal did the Living
Tribunal basically decreed that the
Infinity Gauntlet could not be used
under any circumstance that the gems if
brought together would not be able to
work in unison and so Adam warlock in
turn formed the Infinity watch which as
I I forgot it was Drax at a story before
people get reminded they were like
distracted estroux he ate one of the
Infinity stones because he thought it
was a jelly bean yes he did yes
he did he ate an infinity stone because
it was shaped like a jellybean and he
thought it was a jellybean ah but the
original infinity watch was Gamora and
and pit patrol and Thanos and Adam
warlock and Moon dragon and and Raksha
destroyer and so what this did is it
goes directly into this this whole
scenario now that's kind of where things
get a little hairy
there's the main infinity war story and
then there's all the tions the tie-ins
are not necessary so we're not gonna
worry about that too much but for the
main story itself we basically pick up
in the aftermath of all these
doppelgangers that have been running
around now the first issue just kind of
like showed us things were popping off
and we didn't really know why all we
knew was that the the villain The Magus
had returned and there was like a
doppelganger of phantoms and in the
doppelganger of a couple other villains
here I'm sorry a couple of the
superheroes here and they're on earth
but we didn't really know what the main
purpose was what the main basis behind
it was what this does is it reveals a
lot of that stuff now some of the stuff
that that kind of reveals where the
doppelgangers came from that comes from
the quasar tie-in which we'll just kind
of run over in terms of like what where
they're coming from or one over that in
this video and leave the rest of the
tie-in out because the rest of the time
is not very important but the overall
gist is that Reed Richards has basically
brought together like all the
superheroes on earth now there's a
couple things that I want you guys to
bear in mind here so what this does is
this comes in the midst of Marvel in the
mind in the early 1990s the story was
like 90 92 or something like that so
there's characters like Wonder Man who's
just really strong and has a power
flight and your standard abilities of
superheroes strong guy and the various
other people who were wearing like those
navy blue and yellow x-men outfits
that's X Factor that's the newest
version of The X Factor team so like
Polaris with the green hair Forge who's
the government liaison between X Factor
and the federal government you've also
got like quasar a handful of people
different things like that it's
basically like the entire superhero
roster now there's a reason for this
during the original Infinity Gauntlet
story that story was not designed to be
standalone those were designed to be
Silver Surfer stories and what had
happened was Marvel said no we want to
experiment with a summer event like we
want like a huge summer event that's
gonna pop everything off so we got
infinity gone this the reason why Marvel
does summer events all the time now is
because of the success of the Infinity
Gauntlet story a couple of the things
you got like vision for example who's
all white this is at a point in time
when you eventually had at one point you
had Simon Williams who is Wonder Man
and vision is based off Simon Williams
meaning that like some and Williams
brain patterns more or less ruin the
mind of vision in order to kind of like
rework his character and reinvigorate
him Marvel wiped all that away and so he
was for lack of a better word rebooted
and the result was that he came back is
just like this all white
who had no recollection of who he was
before this gathering together of all
the various superheroes by Reed Richards
it's designed to basically tell
everybody about like what's going on
like what it is this happening and a lot
of people don't really know I mean
there's a couple instances where people
have encountered things but for the most
part they're not here like Iron Man's
not here for example like Wolverine is
not here there's a couple characters
here and then we'll talk about them a
little bit more here in a second but at
this point what we do is we shift our
attention to came to conquer and to
Doctor Doom now the two of them met up
in the first issue the video that came
before this in part one but the reason
why we have like these two guys meeting
up is because of the fact that there is
just like these massive sources of
energy that are popping up across the
universe and people are basically trying
to trace them well switch over to
Galactus here in a minute and he's
basically doing the same thing but the
whole gist here is to ask the question
like what's going on like what are these
energy sources because coming directly
out of Infinity Gauntlet everybody's on
edge like the universe was almost
totally destroyed by Thanos but for
Doctor Doom it came to conquer the
reason why these two guys are paired up
is historically speaking in Marvel
Comics when it comes to their
publications they're always trying to
acquire absolute power with Doctor Doom
and Secret Wars in 1984 it was stealing
the power of Galactus and then stealing
the power of the Beyonder it's always
that way when it's with his character
and that's what he's doing here I mean
it's really one of these things where
like their goals are similar in the
sense that like they're trying to find
the source of his energy but once the
source is located they're gonna break
off and they're basically gonna end up
fighting each other because Cain the
Conqueror wants to do the same thing he
wants to gain all this power for himself
and so ultimately they end up figuring
out like where this power resides or at
least getting an idea of like where the
signals coming from so at this point we
switch over to Monster Island now
monster Island's heard a couple purposes
in Marvel Comics one it was literally a
place where like all these monsters hung
out and it was cool for what it was I
mean if you don't know about Monster
Island don't stress it it's not a great
big huge deal but Monster Island is a
place that nobody ever really goes to
for a variety of reasons one because it
never really have a reason to and two
because it's a pretty hostile place but
the fact remains that the the infinity
watch meeting up alongside here with
Thanos is simply the idea that Thanos
had shown up here after realizing
they're like Magus had returned and
Magus was up to something now we will
talk about Magus here in a second
because I'm sure a lot of the guys are
probably kind of curious who this guy is
but the big question that anybody has is
why is stano's here and that's where
it's kind of revealed to us that Thanos
is like this secret member of the
Infinity watch Adam warlock didn't tell
anybody else
fifth anos is guarding one of the
Infinity stones he's guarding the
reality stone the Release he's supposed
to be and so without having learned what
was going on what he's basically done is
shown
pr2 Adam warlock and say look things are
dire now one the Magus is returned to
the Magus is trying to gain absolute
power and three he's channeling some
source of some source of energy and we
don't know what it is the only way to
really know definitively what's going on
here is to go to the only real source of
information that's out there they can
give us all our answers we have to go to
the infinity well in the realm of
mistress death now this is a dangerous
proposition and everyone knows it
because if you travel to the realm of
mistress death and she gets angry she
won't let you leave which means your
soul will be confined there for all
eternity but from here we pick up with
the arrival of Galactus now I believe
this is during the era of these second
iteration of the defenders those you
guys who don't know the defenders as
they existed in Marvel Comics are
nothing like what you saw in the Netflix
TV show the Netflix TV show was just
taken the name of the defenders and
giving us a reason to have a team of
Iron Fist Luke Cage Jessica Jones and
daredevil working together in Marvel
Comics the defenders were actually
pretty cool originally it was Doctor
Strange a silver surfer and a mother
Submariner and then the Incredible Hulk
it was actually a pretty powerful team
now over the years in Marvel Comics that
kind of gave way because the defenders
just sort of lost you know lost
publicity and they lost interest from
fans because the x-men stories were
getting so good and the Avenger stories
were getting better and so Marvel began
to shift it up and by the time he got to
the 1990s which is around this point in
time the defenders basically turned into
a series of black ops teams that were
created by Doctor Strange and he would
grab like various superheroes and then
take them on secret mystical missions
and stuff once Doctor Strange and these
guys show up to earth and they see this
huge power signature Doctor Strange is
kind of freaks out and says okay look
there's a massive amount of energy here
and Galactus says fine this is one of
those sources let us take off and let's
find some more because when you're
Galactus and you're looking around here
he's not seeing anything that he hasn't
seen before the question is what is the
source of these energy signatures that
are being put off and so at this point
we switch over back to Four Freedoms
Plaza now Hawkeye alongside a handful of
others are basically about to be
besieged by like all these different
doppelgangers but before we get into
that we switch back over to Adam warlock
this is 1990s comics guys this is how it
went like you just went back and forth
and back and forth and back and forth
and they got a little bonkers and they
got a little crazy in terms of how it
all happened but this is where we get
the huge expose what we end up doing is
having the infinity watch appear to the
infinity well now this is not the first
time the Thanos has ever used it Thanos
is aware of the infinity well and he
knows what is capable of it and like we
said before the Infinity well will give
you the answer to any question you ask
but only if you ask it correctly only if
you ask it the right way and so because
of that when the question is asked
what's going on with everything we're
basically given like this great big huge
exposition and what we're essentially
told is of course kind of like this
reiteration of the history between Adam
warlock
and the Magus so to kind of reiterate
this for people who were new The Magus
is basically just a future version of
Adam warlock and like a future storyline
Adam warlock would be corrupted by the
soul gem that he wears and the result is
that he'll become like this insane
religious zealot who forms a group
called the universal Church of truth the
idea was that the Magus had basically
shown up and then when Adam warlock
realized that was his future he along
side Thanos defeated the Magus
but Thanos only allied himself with Adam
warlock because at the same time that
was going on Dan'l's was trying to find
a way to acquire the Infinity stones for
the first time and so what he did is he
allied himself with Adam and then
started siphoning off energy from the
soul stone since he couldn't handle it
readily because those who wield it long
enough are corrupted by it and so
ultimately Adam warlock in antenna's win
and then Thanos uses the energy from the
soul geom to create the big synthetic
gym the first time he gained the
Infinity stones
before he learned about the Infinity
Gauntlet and so the result is that when
Magus was defeated his tias future was
destroyed and he was just gone forever
there was no indication that he would
ever return instead what happened was
that when Thanos gained the Infinity
Gauntlet and that whole storyline
storyline ensued when it ended in Adam
warlock gained the Infinity Gauntlet for
himself subconsciously what he actually
ended up doing is purging good and evil
for himself and so he is a completely
impartial being and that's where this
whole thing comes from is because when
he purged the good and evil out of his
body it saw the return of the madness
now what it also did is a create goddess
who's the main villain in infinity
crusade so we may or may not cover that
with this revelation Adam warlock
basically comes to the realization that
when the Magus was reborn he was reborn
in this kind of nexus of realities and
so while the infinity world doesn't know
everything that Magus was doing what we
do know is that the Magus basically
traveled around to these different
realities and stole cosmic cubes now
this is one of the big differences in
Marvel Comics it's well established that
the Infinity stones only work in their
native universe and it's been that way
for some time you couldn't take like the
Infinity Gauntlet from from the Marvel
Cinematic Universe and take it into the
comic book universe
it wouldn't work the cosmic cubes don't
work like that because the cosmic cubes
gain their energy they gain their power
from the beyonders from the beyond verse
and the beyonders exists outside of the
multiverse and so so long is that cosmic
cube is charged with energy
you can do anything with it because it
was created outside of the universes and
it's not constrained to any one universe
so that's why the cosmic keeps work in
any reality regardless of where you use
them they're just magical wishing boxes
that serve their purpose but the fact
remains picking back up with spider-man
for a second he suddenly met by the
arrival of you know this evil version of
Hawkeye who tries to subdue him he's
ultimately defeated because you know
it's Hawkeye and then of course Ironman
steps in and then Ironman basically
defeats defeat spider-man
that's the question is this really kind
of being asked here is what's going on
with all these various evil versions
evil counterparts of characters that are
showing up and so what happens is that
where the Magus is observing the
Infinity watch you know alongside this
doppelganger Thanos where they're
observing the Infinity watch and
watching them gain all this information
through this well they ultimately decide
to cut them off once they believe
they've gained enough than enough
information and so what happens is the
Magus essentially disrupts the cloaking
abilities of the Infinity watch and
mistress death becomes aware of their
presence and that's why I say this is
dangerous because with mistress death
come rolling in like if she gets mad
enough like they're not gonna be allowed
to leave and so ultimately once they
realize what's what's happening with
mistress death as soon as she shows up
they immediately say we got to get out
of here we got a bolt and so they end up
teleporting out and that's that really
kind of you know leaves them and
whatever their next state is but from
here we pick up in Four Freedoms
positive with like Reed Richards and the
various superheroes and so on and so
forth and so what is it happening here
is that the various argument that's made
from these from the skies is we have
basically have doppelgangers of us
running around trying to attack us has
anybody experienced anything like this
and then suddenly will rain chimes in
now to kind of step aside for a second
and the previous video will rain defeat
of one of his doppelgangers but the
question is where are these
doppelgangers coming from okay in Marvel
Comics you have something called the
dimension of manifestations and now the
dimension of manifestations is basically
where cosmic entities go in order to
gain what are called embodies or
physical forms the cosmic entities are
ideologies they're abstract they don't
really have a true form they could give
themselves one if they wanted to but
they usually don't instead what they do
is they travel to the realm of dimension
manifestations they speak with a being
called anthropomorphic einde of a
representation or kind of like the
leader of these other dimension and
manifestations and in turn they're given
like an actual physical form that's what
Magus did Matt just basically gained all
these different your cosmic cubes and
then travel to the dimension of
manifestations and had these these
doppelgangers created by anthropomorphic
and then set them loose on
what is it happening is like Wolverines
response is Reed Richards and iron man
are not who they claim to be they're
they're impersonators or doppelgangers
don't really know what's going on but I
know it's not them and so again the
earth superheroes or whatever for the
most part oblivious about what's going
on they don't know about Adam warlock in
the whole infinity watch trying to
figure things out they don't know about
Galactus showing up on earth now a lot
of it was because the Infinity watch did
not want to invoke earth superheroes in
response to the Infinity Gauntlet I
Thanos had all this power and he went
crazy and so on and so forth you know it
becomes walking in with the Infinity
Washington says oh hey by the way I'm
bringing Thanos like Earth superheroes
are gonna freak out but of course
because of the fact that they're
superheroes for the most part don't
really know what's happening from their
perspective all they know is like Reed
Richards brought them all together
Wolverine fought a doppelganger now
Wolverine saying that Reed Richards and
Iron Man aren't who they claim to be and
the reaction of the superheroes is
exactly what we would expect well do you
have any evidence for this Wolverine lie
do you have any ID like can you prove
this no one really has a reason to
believe Wolverine and there's only
evidence is well the nose knows like I'm
smelling them and they don't say they
smell kind of like Reed and an Iron Man
but like not exactly like them but the
fact you may is likely hit up Xavier and
they said can you pick anything up now
this is the power of anthropomorphic
into dimension and manifestations when
they create embodies they are by and
large exact identical the only exception
is of course Wolverines ability to smell
them and even like like daredevil picks
up a subtle difference but for Charles
Xavier their brain patterns are exactly
the same they have all the same memories
there's no reason to believe mentally
that there are not Reed Richards and
they're not Iron Man and so because of
this daredevil basically goes through
any kind of you know uses the senses a
little bit and picks up the fact that it
is not actually Reed Richards and it's
not actually iron man ice so that's when
everything begins to visio to descend
into madness because at this point it
suddenly turns them so like monsters do
on Maple Street right like everybody's
attacking everybody else everybody's
just like oh you're the imposter well
you're an impostor and it's just like
this massive state of pandemonium
but the thing that really kind of slows
it all down and really you know kind of
unifies the superheroes is when Reed
Richards basically activates this
massive bomb or the intention of killing
everybody inside the building and that's
a crazy thing where this bomb goes off
it happens at the same time that like
moon dragon shows up to basically
recruit the earth superheroes and that's
the funny thing because when you're
Heather Douglas when you're moon dragon
you're more intertwined with humanity
than like anybody else as part of the
infinity watch for the most part but
showing up and simply saying like we
need to grab the other earth superheroes
because sure they'll freak out at first
but we can count on them
because like they'll be reliable for the
long haul it's disruptive by the fact
that everybody gets blown up basically
it seems like the x-men x-factor the
Avengers the Fantastic Four the whole
nine yards they all get blown to pieces
and what it does is it sets the stage
for Magus because now the only thing he
has to worry about is like the Infiniti
watch and like whatever other beings are
out there but for him it's irrelevant
one because he's got like five or six
cosmic hues at his disposal and two he's
still on the road for his main goal but
with that being said guys we're gonna
bring this video to an end if you are
new here to comments explain it make
sure you guys have the sub button to
become part of the Rob core if you guys
enjoy this video make sure you drop a
like and I will catch you all later
peace